the creator of blame studied
architecture at Parsons in New York and
his background is really obvious because
the story is driven not by dialogue and
not by character development but through
time and space the main character Kelly
just walks for pages and pages and Pages
looking for this thing called the net
terminal Gene while running away from
the city's defense system which is
constantly expanding and is essentially
trying to eliminate all the humans the
lack of dialogue and the sheer scale and
the distance that he's walking through
really slows down the pacing and extends
the timeline that time almost becomes
Irrelevant in the story you can see that
he took a lot of inspiration from
brutalist architecture which was built
around the premise that communal was
more important than the individual hence
being dominant and foreboding and
creating spaces that make you feel
really small while he doesn't use the
characters to convey emotions you do
feel a connection with the characters in
this feeling of being insignificant and
vulnerable and very lost